[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
can you hear me
yeah man can you hear me how do I sound
why aren't you working
oh I can hear you better
hey can you hear me yeah yeah I can hear
you I'm gonna sound okay yeah okay so
was it hard to join that
no
apparently that's like their new little
thing I think uh would do you care what
we use
nah as long as it works so streamlabs
has something where you don't don't have
to use discount uh this Discord to talk
yeah it's it's called Uh collab or
something collab something oh okay does
it cost uh no you cannot but you can
have one person it doesn't cost but
anything more than that it costs uh like
30 bucks a month I don't know okay
so it's good for like one-on-one shows
yeah because I think you can only have a
Max of four so it's like it's kind of
useless if uh you're not having a lot of
people
yeah they said it's called stream last
collab yeah yeah
what's going on Chad I'm sure you've
seen Twitter I'm sure you know it's
what's what's the deal
Jesus Christ
there is a an absurd amount of info that
has came out in a matter of 24 hours
it's crazy man what are we gonna do dirt
you know let's talk about it bro the X
the PlayStation people are running wild
today they're running wild them bastards
run around while any day it doesn't
matter
see I I have a bulletproof vest on so
I'm good I'm good they ain't getting me
they ain't getting me
now it's funny I can see you on the
YouTube but I can't see you here it's
kind of weird
uh so you can't see me at all I can see
you on the YouTube channel but not here
yeah it's just like a blank screen here
but like you see me yeah I see you okay
well I I'll figure it out is that is
that gonna bother you no no it's cool
I'm looking at the YouTube stream too so
okay I'll figure out you know exactly
how to work on that uh this is all new
to me you know I I gotta I gotta figure
it out well what's going on you guys
static show we talked about the past
present future gaming uh we had a little
bit of a break man we we were gone for
like what a month a little probably a
month yeah about a month uh it's it's
it's been one of one hell of a month and
the past 24 hours there's been a lot
going on so uh first off the the the the
the the screen is a little inaccurate
because there's some stuff that's
happened
since I updated this thing uh you know
Xbox layoffs now it is
three
four three
crazy that's what I'm gonna name it
three four three crazy all right so
where we're going to get going to this
man we're going to go into this let's
first off what you've been playing man
because at the end of the day we got to
come back to what we've been playing
that's the most important thing that's
going on what you've been playing uh
well assistant break I I don't know if I
said it before I finished Callisto
protocol uh how'd you like that game I
liked it I liked it a lot it's
unfortunate that the game I guess
flopped
um so I'm not sure if we'll get a sequel
but I like that I thought it was pretty
damn good um
been playing that I just started playing
Gotham Knights recently picked that back
up it's it's not bad it's not bad um
you know so I don't know there's just a
few games I'm trying to play this in my
backlog you know before Dead Space comes
out which I'm really into so
that's about it man
um I started playing Halo again I
started playing some multiplayer again I
listen I don't know you know we're going
to talk about what happened with Joe
Stanton and everything but
um the game plays still solid and Halo
infinite
you know we just got to see what's going
on with the campaign and everything else
brother so we'll talk about it I guess
yeah uh shout out to uh flame with the
two dollar scripture it's good to see
you both back gentlemen rest in peace
three four three we're gonna talk about
it man we're gonna talk about it uh you
know I will save that for a little bit
later part of the show but we will get
to that man we will get to that first
thing I do want to talk about you know
uh you know first off I I've been
playing Echo Generations I've been
playing a lot of that I like that game
actually the uh Lords of gaming.net I
was able to secure us a little exclusive
interview with the Creator you know that
was made by one person
Echo generation one yeah it was pretty
impressive
I always like
like stories like that where the person
that is making it had has like a
a good outcome you know one person
making it had all this success you know
and then I and the the questions that
what happened to it he even said you
know I really inspired to make something
like uh Chrono Trigger and it's an honor
to be considered in the same sentence
Chrono Trigger so it's it's cool gaming
Gamers making games that's why I like to
call it Gamers making games but you know
developers are Gamers too there's no way
around that everyone that really
develops some way shape or forms a gamer
but I think there's something unique and
special about a small time person making
a game and being successful I don't know
why yeah absolutely
all right so let's let's start with this
developer direct because I think that's
a that's a prominent topic I think
there's a lot of stuff going on about
that uh you know for the the mafia
police I'm gonna set that up for 8 30. 8
minutes and 30 seconds
so we're gonna go ahead and get that so
first off it's it's interesting that
they named this developers direct I'm
sure you've talked about a lot on your
podcast I'm not saying that that's a bad
name but it's interesting that they
decided to use
chained Echo that's what the game is
Chained echo my bad uh that's the game
it's called chained Echo oh so it's not
Echo generation no it's called chain
Deco I don't know why I call it Echo
generation that's a completely different
other game that game's good yeah yeah I
honestly play Echo Echo Generations I
never played chain knuckle yeah uh chain
that goes I would say I don't Echo
Generations was such a good game but
anyway it's interesting that they use
the word Direct in this like I I'm very
interested in that because I feel like
out of all the stuff they could use they
they chose something that is in the
similar vein to uh you know uh the state
of play Nintendo Direct they chose that
direct word for uh for a reasoning and
what I want to ask you about this direct
thing is I want to ask you
is that do you think that they're gonna
go in that kind of vein where it's going
to be hit with you know maybe developers
talking over it or do you think it's
going to be maybe a hybrid between
something like
you know um inside Xbox and uh a state
of play
um well I think it will be more like a
state of play or Nintendo Direct I think
you know just like because they
announced it and said there will be no
hosts or anything like that I I honestly
wouldn't mind a developer talking over
the gameplay that'll be fine
um you know if they want to say certain
amount you know certain things that's
fine um like I said I prefer that
because you know we know how in the past
it's like Xbox they have they actually
had that show when they really didn't
have much content so that show was just
two hours and boring
but this is going to be 45 minutes
I always like the uh
like the way the Nintendo uh directs in
the state of plays were you know just
really quick not a lot of talking just
showing the gameplay and moving to the
next game and then the show's over with
I like that so if that's what they're
going to do I think that's good and I'm
all for it
my thing is I I really want to make sure
that they know that like look we don't
mind the the personalities the
influencers talking I think the
disconnect is who they choose I feel
like for the most part besides like
ricari like they've always been a hit
and miss with me you know they they
didn't seem like they were there for the
games they seem like they're there for a
paycheck that happened to them to do it
there's no passion there and there's a
lot of the influencing people and then
not to mention I do feel like this is an
issue when you have PR making these
events
because I feel like PR is going to try
to PR you know what I'm saying like
that's why I feel like influencers and
stuff should be making these events like
when these people do these type of
events they need to be reaching out to
influencers that's in that direct
Community to be hosting these events
because there's a little bit of of a
connection right there you know we don't
work for Microsoft we they they gave us
this information we we absorbed it and
and then after a couple days of
absorbent now we're presenting it to you
you know what I'm saying like because I
feel like it feels like a giant
marketing ad and there's nothing wrong
with that but when it comes to how
inside Xbox did it's just like you're
talking about the stuff no one cares
about yeah and then you're not talking
about the stuff people do care about
yeah I agree and that's what inside Xbox
was they talked about a lot of stuff
like you said no one cared about out of
all of the inside Xboxes I would say
maybe one was okay and I remember that
one because they announced a lot of
backwards compatible games
um but if this is just going to focus on
um games that's coming in the future in
the short term I I love it I love it and
if they're going to really focus on um
you know they have a dedicated show
based on some of the first party games
like Starfield or whatever else in the
future I love that also because I did
like when Sony did a show based on on uh
you know last of us too or ghost of
sushima or even gt7 that crap but you
know I did like for them like went like
when they did that so I think it'll be
um you know that would let us know if
the Xbox has a lot more content on the
way in the past you know Xbox didn't
have a lot of content they really
couldn't do stuff like this but now they
can and I think that's that's a plus to
see them like having a smaller show to
show some upcoming games with some
release dates hoping yeah and I feel
like
you know
this is okay let me ask you a question
but I'm I'm curious your your response
we haven't really talked too much you
know we've been uh dming a little bit
back and forth uh but my question to you
is like how would you want them to do
information throughout the year like you
got the E3 stuff
um you know EXO they used to do let's
say that Phil Spencer popped in there
right now and you pulled that green
screen back and he's like dirt how do
you want me to to do these e3s these
shows throughout the year what was you
what would your response be
my response would be um I like the Xbox
developer direct idea I like that to
maybe give some release dates uh like
not just the first party games of like
maybe some games going directly into
Game Pass if they can some third-party
games or some indie games
I would like for them to have like a big
game like Starfield or rare fall or
Forza to have their own little smaller
small personal show before the game
releases I still want the E3 to be the
show where they announced new stuff
unannounced games you know games in the
future I still want that and if they're
going to have you know show around
um you know Gamescom that doesn't have
to be an E3 type of show but just you
know just to show the uh you know show
out show some things that still yet to
come throughout the year things like
that so I would say about
three smaller shows like uh developers
direct throughout the year as well as E3
Gamescom Tokyo game show because last
year's Tokyo game so I actually thought
that was a pretty good show they showed
a lot of Japanese stuff coming from 2x
box and I thought that was a pretty good
show so yeah that's what I would like
about three of these smaller shows
um whatever like two or three uh shows
focused on one game and you know the big
shows like E3 for the future stuff
I think the the thing I would want them
to do now there's a couple ways they can
do it first thing I would want them to
do is do the show this this direct thing
to fill out games
uh you know don't show Too Much gameplay
in these shows because I want that time
to be used to announce other stuff you
know what I'm saying like use these
developer directs like a month before
kind of like Nintendo Direct to say to
play where they dedicate a whole one of
these to a game with a little bit of
smaller announcements uh you know throw
your game pass you know you know they
just come out randomly and they're like
these are the games coming in Game Pass
right like maybe every three months you
have one of these developer directs and
it tells you all the Game Pass games
that you're going to get for the next
three months and it tells you uh you
know games that's coming out in the
three months and they show you deep
Dives and stuff like Starfield et cetera
Etc and then then you get to E3 and what
I want from E3 is I want that to be the
next 12 months that they keep the 12
month thing where they show looks yeah
this is what's coming out now this is
what's coming out at the beginning of
next year and this is what's coming out
at the end of this year and then once
you get to the you know three or four
months later you're about novemberish
then instead of putting that stuff on
the on the
on the Video Game Awards they do an XO
and the XO is like we've showed you
independent games we showed you why you
should be into an Xbox ecosystem and
these directs we showed you what the
next 12 months the immediate future is
that you're going to get from at E3 EXO
is going to be what's beyond that year
these is the roadmap this is the updated
roadmap this is what's going on these
are the games that we're going to be
playing in the future
okay
can't you yeah I mean yeah that makes a
lot of sense
um it's all about you know the future
but like the only thing that I would say
maybe I would disagree with in my
opinion is the 12 month thing at least
do 18 months because
well I think Xbox roadmap I believe they
had to announce those games right they
had to announce Fable Perfect Dark
because even though those games were too
far out of the world are really far out
Xbox had to announce something because
if they didn't announce those games they
wouldn't have nothing to announce in
those shows the last couple years so
they had to announce those games but
the 12 month thing was okay
but but it also seems to me like maybe
should be 18 months no within the next
18 months because if you do see that
June to June that's obviously 12 months
you do june to you know next holiday
season of the following year I think
that makes a little bit more sense to me
but I understand where you're coming
from
sorry just keep talking
oh okay so
yeah so you know like I said I think
it's a good thing that we're able to
have these shows now because
that means Xbox has content on the way
they they weren't always in a position
where they could do these types of shows
you know like we mentioned inside Xbox
and for the most part people felt inside
Xbox was trash
because they didn't show anything new
they talked about a lot of stuff a lot
of stuff that we didn't care about and I
think the issue with that isn't
necessarily
the fact that we don't see anything new
it's the fact that we have so many games
in the works so many games in the talk
so many games that's like look we don't
want to see 12 months because you've
announced all these games we want to see
these games too and that's why I feel
like the XO would be a good thing
because it's like look this is the EXO
is going to be focused on road map this
is what we're aiming for I feel like
they need to be very more transparent on
what stuff's going on you know that's
where they would announce delays and
stuff like you know what I'm saying like
imagine a Marvel
map for every phase that's what I want
this event to be where it's mainly
focused on just telling us stuff that we
expect to see telling us stuff that it
is down the pipeline let's say that
gears is ready to talk about their game
they throw that on the map you know what
I'm saying right and you know I think
someone a developer going up there
briefly talking about stuff that's going
on briefly talking about what they want
to do with this game you know Fable we
want to be an Albion we want to be kind
of a reboot of the franchise stuff like
that is what I want to see yeah I got
you yeah I see what you're saying no
because that kind of stuff is important
you know because we like we really do
want to know more about the games that's
like in the works
in the works so
yeah man what's up everybody in the chat
what's up y'all yeah so that that's
that's all I'm saying like and I get it
I think
18 months is fine but I think the
12-month thing would work if they just
keep up with it for a couple years
because now you know we want to see
gratitude gameplay on stuff that we're
talking about and I think I do think to
a point people get upset with they're
being an hour now like what's what I'm
looking for like five years between us
and Fable fight us in a vowed and I
think you know sure you wouldn't know
some of the the road map in certain
games but I think it would set
expectations to where look this is this
is EXO this is dedicated to the future
you know games that are at this event
don't expect to see for a couple years
hmm and I I think that would that would
work well now obviously people
they they want to know stuff so maybe
they just need more shows overall it's
just going to be interesting to see how
this developer direct goes in with
everything else I'm very interested to
see that well I will say this I don't
know if you heard recently that Neil
druckman was saying um
the last of us too and Uncharted 4 they
announced those games too early because
it pretty much it put a lot of pressure
on the team
I understand where he was coming from
because he was pretty much saying that
because we announced them so early
people know about it so people yo they
always yo man when this last verse 2
coming out when this Uncharted 4 coming
out putting pressure on the team to you
know
work faster so Neil Dragon said he's not
going to do that anymore announce the
game that far out like I mentioned Xbox
had to announce those games in 2020.
they had to announce state of the K3 uh
uh
in those games because they didn't have
any other games
so they had to announce those games but
I see what you're saying if they do the
12-month thing
boom and they're there to stick with it
though
and I would like for them to let us know
ahead of time because last year they
told us the at the show you know yeah
we're doing 12 months so he was like
damn you know
um but I do see what you're saying
because if this year they will show
maybe hellblade 2 and the vowel you know
stuff like that stuff that's within the
next 12 months
um that would make a lot of sense so I
do see what you're saying but
I don't know man I think the only thing
with that there will still be that
desire to know what's what else is
coming
um two or three years down the line so
it's yeah it's a tough situation we
might actually just see people just
straight up
okay here's the next 12 months
and we're just going to give you these
developer directs to and heighten these
games show you what they're playing like
you know we might not ever get another
road map like we used to and and part of
me is disappointed in that but the other
part of me is like
I am tired of talking about the same
games for years
I am tired about where's Fable where's
the vowed I am low-key tired of these
Studios and Publishers revealing games
that they act likes a year or two away
but in all sense it's next generation or
the end of the generation yeah uh so
it's it's again it's a it's a give and
take I do think it's a give and take
yeah yeah
but we'll go ahead and move on with that
man you know uh
I don't know if you saw
you know we got something called
scale bow oh man
so do you know anything about what's
going on with scalebound right now no
not really I'm hearing rumors what's
going on whatever you heard yeah so
shout out to Nick over there at uh Xbox
era he heard that they're in the early
stalks of rebooting
uh not rebooting but re-finishing
scalebound and
all right so I've heard rumors about
this before really yes but every time I
hear something about scalebound I roll
my eyes and like just let this game this
damn game die that's where I'm at it's
just like at this point
just look it's not coming back it's not
coming back but it it is what it is you
know I I get it here's what I think
do I think this is true
no I I don't I've I don't find a good
world where scoutbound comes out
do I think it's possible yes
because I do feel like Microsoft is done
with the publisher thing I think they
know they can't keep getting away with
that you know what I'm saying I think
after this Activision thing if they
they're gonna buy smaller Studios
and I feel like
it would be dumb to think that Platinum
Games isn't part of that
they're very competent Studio A lot of
people love their games so that would be
a studio that I would definitely think
that is a possibility that Microsoft is
looking at the new quote to acquire but
my question to you Dart is if
what conditions would you say would have
to happen before scale bound would
officially get a green light to come
back uh we got a five dollar subscribe
from the angry therapist and D Let It
Die
dead
okay so what what what which one
listen man if for Microsoft to
do a scale bound Platinum Games they
have to have a contract where Platinum
Games look if you guys don't finish this
game within I don't know two years
there's going to be some consequences uh
I don't know it's a breach of contract I
don't know they need something written
on paper
because we all heard that rumors about
what happened before with scale bound
and platinum games just didn't do what
they were supposed to do with that game
we've we heard that you know like the
game was playing terrible and a year
later the game was in the same state so
it was like no man
um this is how I feel about scale bomb
though addict let me tell you I said
this on WBZ a couple nights ago
scale bound
the cancellation the scale bound
happened right when I first started my
YouTube channel it was literally my
second video on my channel I I have a
video about scale found two okay okay it
was it was my second I had 22
subscribers it was my second video on my
channel and then I had 22 people saying
that they were so looking forward to
scalebound didn't you oh my God this is
what happened it was like it was like
yeah we we won't scale but that was the
only game I was gonna buy Xbox four yes
I'm gonna buy Xbox for scalable oh they
messed and then they're like did you put
did you play bayonet no did you play
anything else mate no
I was going to buy your Xbox One for
scalebound they are so terrible so scale
bound to me I'm like kind of like like
with the angry therapist MB said let it
die now I won't lie if this is true I
will start capping immediately all right
I was like Kevin said yo Xbox got scale
ball coming yeah let's go so I would
definitely start capping but in reality
I just want the game to just die just
die
um
I now I was interested in the game I
thought it looked cool
um the concept seemed pretty cool but
for this game to really come back it has
to be
Platinum Games Focus
they can't be doing several games at one
time their Studio needs to focus on
scale bound if this is true and if I was
Microsoft I would make sure of that
like damn it you guys are going to do
this game and do it right
that's all I'm going to say about scale
my attic
I think the only way that this happens
the only way that this game gets bought
I mean gets made
is if Microsoft approached Platinum
Games and they were very serious in
Platinum Games use that to leverage to
get the game green lit like look we
understand what we did was wrong we
understand maybe our priorities wasn't
100 straight
if we sign on to you and and let you buy
our company
we want to make that right and we would
appreciate if you'd let us finish
that game now if XBox bought them every
all best off you know that's that's a
good thing but
until then I'm still kind of like yeah
if it happens it happens if it doesn't
good that's kind of why I'm at
which yeah at this point that's exactly
where I am I'm like look
it is what it is there's nothing we
could do about it uh you know people
need to stop expecting scalebound to
come back because it's not if it does
come back do you think that that would
be a crazy E3 moment
it would it would be a crazy E3 moment
that um there's two games that I feel
like would blow the roof off of each
other
scale bound rebooting and coming back
and a rice in a room too yes right side
wrong two would be bigger than scale
Bound in my opinion
yeah I agree because rice and Rome's
actually had a game to generate a little
bit of hype yeah scalebound would be be
crazy it just you know
I hope it happens like I really do
because you know when you when you see
what's his name over there at play uh at
Platinum
you could tell he knew he was in the
wrong because that dude never you know
ever amidst defeat he always acts like
he he's 100 in a riot on everything and
you could tell when he was talking he's
like yeah we messed up that we if they
let us fix it we'll fix it but you know
I don't blame them for not letting us
fix it they let Xbox get that ass
whooped for five four five years before
they admitted that they were part of the
reason the game was canceled also Bailey
and Xbox get their legs beat
specifically Phil Spencer they people
was killing field Spencer on the Xbox
bro I remember yeah they should have
been more open with the conditions that
was going on
see I'm not a huge fan of platinum games
but I will say
is the games that they 100 focus on the
bayonettas the the near automatas uh
well the games that they 100 Vanquish
the games that the majority of their
because they the problem is they they
have a hundred percent of a studio and
they split it eight ways to make eight
different games and they have like five
six people in the in the closet making
this game eight or nine people in the
lunchroom making this game and that's
the issue because then when you do that
you have ideal splitting obviously they
have some form of the vets in their
Studio split to all these projects they
they have visions going through multiple
different projects but if you laser
focus that studio into one to two
projects I honestly and truly feel like
they can make great games
Metal Gear rise and that's another one
with Donald who's hey man look Donna
Taco we actually agreed on something
Astro chains
five dollar strip trap from the angry
therapist MD even if they make it it
will not live up to the hype I hope it
will if they remade that game I would
hope it would live up to the hype
everyone has because imagine dirt just
Just Close Your Eyes in a match that
that scale bound comes out
and it's a 90 plus Metacritic everyone's
loving it it's it's brought dragons to
the next era of of gaming you know I
think I do think the concept of that
game was done was was solid it's just
maybe we don't 100 know what happened I
do think Microsoft had a little bit to
do with maybe setting expectations on
like using Co-op and stuff that didn't
pan out so well for the hardware uh you
know because I think both parties had a
small part to play I think Platinum
Games probably had more of the the pie
of turns of the issues and who was wrong
but I do think Xbox had a little bit of
that pie but I hope it happens man you
know especially like rice in a Rome I
would love if they would just give that
game another chance
they were saying killings Thing 2 would
bring down a house yeah what yeah it
would absolutely bring down and I think
Killer Instinct 2 has a better chance of
coming back than any these games so well
I'm about 80 sure there's a rice in a
rope too in the world really but I I
don't think it's going to be an XBox
exclusive I think it's going to be a
multi-plat and I think that
that's not a good look and you know what
would be worse start that sucker came
out as a PlayStation exclusive oh that
would be terrible do you remember when
people were starting to think that the
next Allen wake would be a PlayStation
exclusive because people was like yo
like remember Xbox sold the rights back
to remedy when they gave them the rights
back for Alan Wake and people say he's
gonna be a PlayStation exclusive
uh like somebody's gonna buy a remedy
and I was like oh please don't let it be
a PlayStation
yeah I agree with Carolina maybe a scale
buyers coming back it should be a single
player only game I I think it should be
I think Platinum Games don't really mess
with too much in the co-op sensation and
I think maybe there is a lot of
unexperienced stuff going on there that
they couldn't get stuff working because
they don't necessarily have worked on
stuff like that before but I bet you
they they came with them with that ideal
like here's the thing Microsoft probably
pushed it a little bit more than they
should have but Platinum game said we
got you we can do that and a studio like
Platinum Games even though that I don't
like a lot of their games they're
they're very veteran studio if they told
you something you should believe it
because of how old they are and how many
hit games they've made they've made a
few 90 plus Metacritic games
they did
yeah I'm pretty sure they've made 90
plus games
Babylon fall
yeah hold up Metacritic
uh hey
let's let's see you made a good good
point though attic when you said they're
a great Studio but because they were
mercenaries they were trying to work as
much as possible
that whole team was split up to like
eight eight different games
you know I remember they made that
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle game that
was below average they made a
Transformer game they they they was
working on scale bound they you know
they was working on so many different
games you know because they're trying to
eat you know they're they're trying to
make as much as they can but
uh that didn't show the full
you know Talent of the studio because
like you said so many people working on
different things
near automata like that game was pretty
decent I bought it but I never really
didn't play it
I mean it's like you know you look at
games like that just games in general
man like they they have made some very
successful games but at the end of the
day you can be as successful as you want
if you're not
coming out there and and promising on
and delivering on promises it's going to
be very rough for you man it's gonna be
very rough look okay so Bayonetta 2 was
a was a 92 I got it up now
uh okay okay that
I
have done something that I've never done
put it on
did I was legitly panicking I I
accidentally pushed a different shortcut
and it looked really weird Okay so Bay
92
uh for is that I painted see what on the
switch was it I think it was exclusive
to the switch
yeah
not the switch no three was exclusive to
the switch man that two was exclusion to
the Wii U I believe all right so I'll
just read off the 90s and 80s they have
Bayonetta two on the switch so that's
probably like a remake of some sort I
don't really count those because I feel
like you can't realistically review
another game that's already been out and
have a valid opinion on it because it's
already been reviewed your opinion on
the games probably already into some
form of bias because it's already been
out
uh Bayonetta two again so clearly near
automata Game of the Year Edition
Bane added the original one for the 360.
I like that yeah 90 near automata 90.
Bay that on the PC 90. Bayonetta
Bayonetta two so that was the the Dual
Edition
90. near automata chain uh astral chain
87. okay the original Nero automata ps4
version was 88.
uh then you have Bayonetta on the PS3
which is the 87. the wonderful 101 uh
remaster 85
then you have Vanquish 84 both of them
uh Metal Gear Rising Revenge
uh was a 83 Mad World 81
and yeah that's all the 80s and 90s like
pretty good I just named probably 10 10
games maybe even 13 14. like that's a
lot of games people realize how many
years it took that that's 20 years worth
of games
yeah that's pretty impressive and now
that you say that that's actually pretty
impressive I mean yeah that's pretty
good yeah and then they made that
Transformers Devastation for it see look
they're a hit and miss because all of
this all of this fluff was because they
had to make these games with their
company to go out of business
like rainey's uh Arcane uh the wonderful
101 uh Star Fox hero I forgot about that
uh the legend of core I actually like
that the Legend of Korra game I played a
lot of that Infinite Space baboon Falls
of 46. is that one of their is that one
of their IPs or is that something they
made for someone
I think they made that for Sony didn't
they uh yeah I don't know if Sony owns
it score Enix I think Square Enix is
publishing it oh I don't know but it was
it was a garbage game uh you know a lot
of people didn't like it that's a that's
a question I do have for you do you
think that part of the the uh issue with
the industry in general is there's too
much
train chasing
yeah yeah I think you know couple games
as a service blew off everyone felt like
they got everybody trying to do the same
thing a couple battle royales did what
everyone feels like they got to do
Battle Royale yeah but I mean you know
it it's a rough business
to where these games are pretty
expensive so you're trying to chase what
works and unfortunately sometimes it
just doesn't work out for these
companies there were so many
um live service games there were so many
um Battle Royale games hero Shooters and
there were so many but like I said
doesn't always work out like that man
you know like like people try to do
what they're gonna do but doesn't always
work
yeah so it is what it is I I hope they
get they stuff together I really do yeah
um you know I never want a studio to go
out of business I might joke about it
you know I'm joked about I've joked to
that about in the past that Kojima
deserves to be in a straight jacket yeah
uh but do I really think the man needs
to put on a straight jacket that's
debatable
I don't be one of these Studios to go
out of business like we were talking
about Calista protocol and I was like
it's unfortunate the game didn't sell
well you know we we cracked jokes about
PlayStation being behind the game and
all that stuff but at the end of the day
I don't like to see students because I'm
a gamer before I'm an Xbox fan you know
what I'm saying I'm a gamer first and um
I like to play video games so seeing
um video game companies shut down is
something I don't like to see no one
wants to see that and the thing is is we
don't know alternative versions in the
future where these games because they
never they were never giving a full
Financial backing for a full game they
want to make could have ended up making
the next GTA could it end up making the
next big game like that Epic
pretty much like did a Hail Mary with
fortnite as a as like a a defense game
yeah and then when they saw the
popularity that that pubg was getting
they're like look I think we could do
that better and they took that and now
that is arguably one of the most
influential games in the gaming industry
absolutely bro absolutely hey you know
with something you just said that I want
to um kind of be buttled you said nobody
wants to see a gaming company close out
that's not true because there's a lot of
people happy about the layoffs today bro
a lot of yeah there's a lot of weirdos
they're using this ammunition bro I know
you're on Twitter you might see maybe
you got some people blocked they're
using it as ammo
okay see
there's people that I know that do for
trolling purposes like they're just
trying to get a rise out of people but
if people are generally on Twitter and
generally happy not up front generally
happy that people got laid off in the
thousands
you are an idiot you are you just need
to delete your Twitter you need to to
maybe you need some therapy fam well
just some there there's a bunch of them
out there bro a lot of them need
something I would never
um you know wish for somebody to lose
their job as a man
as a husband a father
people depend on me my wife my kids they
depend on me
and if I can't provide for them I can't
imagine that because it will be very you
know it'll be very difficult it'll be
devastating as a man to go to that
situation and obviously this doesn't
isn't isn't men but I'm sure these
people some of these people are are
parents you know they have households
they have homes I'm sure they'll be able
to get another gig but it's still got to
be stressful initially you know what I'm
saying so I'm sure we'll talk about that
in a few
it is what it is uh you know we're about
to get to that unfortunately let's just
go ahead and get straight over to it so
we are at 43 minutes and 45 seconds
we're going to talk about your head yeah
we're gonna talk about the Halo Fiasco
we're gonna talk about the layoffs in
general so for those of you that's
watching from under a rock
but we got the five dollar scripture
from El Nina probably butchered that but
we're gonna move right past it these
layoffs is the reason I will gladly be
buying 10 copies of awkwards Legacy
for the developers yo Eli 99 we'll be
real with you I don't got that game so
you know if you're going to buy 10 give
me one man yeah you know you know people
sitting here saying they're gonna buy
Hogwarts Legacy in the bundles me and
dirt will gladly take one of them
gladly yeah I I'm sure you could you
know for people on the Xbox land you
know you can gift this guy I don't know
about that PlayStation Fiasco you can't
do that over there are they in the stone
ages but over here in the Xbox land we
can easily take a get a code because if
you just go and buy them just to buy
them you know people on here on this
chat people on Twitter you know what
they say they're like we're gonna say
stuff you ain't no different than the
PlayStation people capping for something
you ain't gonna do you know if you go
really sit there on your stone own and
buy 10 copies of it
I take one of them that's it that's it
yeah man so all right so
there's there's been ten
thousand jobs lost yeah
and it's it's
um it's very upsetting it's very
upsetting so uh it does look like 343
was affected and some of Bethesda and
the white looked like that I saw on
Twitter is a lot of marketing people got
laid off uh which is interesting that
there wasn't a lot of the gaming portion
laid off you know what I'm saying like
sure you had like 60 people here
probably a lot of marketing but it's
forums like the developers and stuff the
only story I really heard of was some
from Bethesda and a lot of people from
Xbox from three four three yeah uh so
that that's interesting because to me
that means that the gaming industry is
doing well enough that they can't
justify those layoffs you know what I'm
saying uh so that that's interesting
first off let's talk about just the
layoffs in general Derek what's your
opinion on
well you know it's obviously unfortunate
um addict because you know you don't
want to see people get laid off uh like
I just said earlier
you know these people have families to
support
they have homes mortgages things like
that um you don't want to see people get
laid off but like I said the game
industry these people can find another
gig I already saw naughty dogs saying
they're hiring which is good
um but as far as Microsoft
I don't think people realize
um in the last four years Microsoft has
hired 77 000 people
um Tom Warren broke it down how many
employees they had from 2019 to 2020 um
uh three
they hired 77 000 people the last four
years Unfortunately they had to let go
10 000 of it uh so so that is
unfortunate for those people
uh but it's not the first time we've
seen layoffs at all
um it's just a part of the life I've
been laid off before I'm not sure if
you've been laid out before it's a part
of life and it's unfortunate it's a it's
unnecessary I mean it's a necessary evil
I should say
um so yeah I hope these people get back
on their feet and I'm sure they will I
saw one guy say you know it sucks that
I'm laid off but I'm about to get jacked
and like he said if I go to the gym and
get Jack because he's going to have some
extra time now
um but yeah I'm pretty sure so far you
you you sit in that chat you sit down we
will get to Halo infinite you know you
don't have to sit there yeah wait I I
literally I open up the first off hold
up I'm gonna have to roast you
Christopher I'm gonna have to roast you
how you come in this chat say why don't
you talk about Halo when literally
the topic is called 343 craziness it's
literally called 343 industry massive
news yeah how are you gonna sit there
and say that we ain't gonna talk about
Halo relax Chris hey shut up Chris man
you're lucky you ain't on my channel
no he'd be blocked if he was on your
channel
as soon as like like Chris name pop up
my mind's blocking because Chris never
comes in to say yo what's up y'all he
just comes in and say Xbox is trash
PlayStation VR is gonna get
shut up
um yeah so like I said it's um
it's it's it's unfortunate it's
unfortunate um but you know we've seen
like Amazon Lego 18 000 people today
like damn
you know I read something about
uh doordash had to let go a bunch of
different people because during Kobe
they kind of blew up and then you know
Kobe calmed me down they say oh damn we
hired too many people so you know it's a
part of life and it sucks it really does
you're not going to hear me fan boring
about it
um it sucks man it sucks and especially
um from from our standpoint we're gaming
three four three
um now like we're gonna get there next
but they got hit like like as far as
Xbox gaming first party three four three
and Bethesda like addicts mentioned and
um they got hit too so yeah it sucks man
it sucks but back to what I was saying
they have hired 77 000 people over the
last four years and unfortunately you
know ten thousand got let go today so
yeah and it's like
I hate that it's happening but at the
same time it is just it's just how
business goes I I wish it didn't go this
way and I wish they could keep their job
but unfortunately
there the the world don't care what I
think and you know for a company that
did make such a a vast big buy for 68
billion dollars
you know it's easy to look at that and
say they can spend that kind of money
why can't they retain 10 000 people yeah
but if they did decisions like that and
didn't cut positions that they didn't
necessarily need at the moment they
wouldn't have the money to pay to to buy
a company for 68 billion dollars I wish
they would 100 I wish they would uh but
at the end of the day just nothing I can
do about it I would definitely love for
them to keep all those jobs and keep all
those people uh but you know I don't
know anything about running a billion
dollar Corporation unfortunately and I
find it weird like awkward for me to
tell a billion dollar Corporation how to
run a billion dollar Corporation right
right a trillion dollar Corporation
because I just yeah I I I don't know I
you know I I did see people were talking
about the CEOs like made like millions
and millions like three or four hundred
million dollars in in conversations from
from hitting goals
um
it's it's it's shitty he's making that
money and they laying off that many
people yeah but
I can't really go too much in on that
either because they put those goals in
place for a reason to encourage the CEO
to run for those numbers uh what I don't
like is when people start laying people
off to make the numbers look better so
they can get paid that's what I don't
like is that happening here I don't know
uh I I don't know enough information on
what's going on I don't know why things
are going off the way it is and my
heart's out to everyone that got laid
off uh it's it's a rough thing you know
you and I don't I feel like these
these companies shouldn't be able to
light people off with almost no notice
like a company should not be able to
just walk in be like yo you out that's
where Unions would stop you know what
I'm saying if there was a union
I've been in the union for 23 years my
my current job I've been at 23 years
been in Union since they want unions
don't allow companies just co-fire
people you if you want to fire somebody
you better have a hell of a reason it
better be a a great reason yeah you
better have proof uh oh you better have
some some something concrete to why
you're letting these people go and if
there was a union
uh it like three four three and Bethesda
they would have had to place them
somewhere else because at my job people
have been
they want to let go or close the
department down they are
uh it is mandatory that they put those
employees somewhere else in the company
you know they can't just fire them so
that's something that the union would uh
stop hopefully they will retain some of
these people and take them somewhere
else where they're needed yeah uh you
know a lot of that's done post after
everything's already been handled so we
don't exactly know if any of that's
gonna happen but I'm very curious to see
if that does happen if
after a certain amount of time goes by
they start giving these other people
that uh you know their job in another
location hey attic I'm sorry coach job
Chris come on bro you know Sony has done
this before
it it might not have been 10 000 people
but they've let people go before too
really Chris that's what you're gonna
say
come on man you ain't your everyday shut
down the team that may drive Club
they close that whole studio down how
about Studio Japan Studio do you
remember that stop it don't act like
Sony stop it bro this is business this
happens in business all the time no act
like Sony Sony shop whole Studios down
it's like you got no job stops Chris
just stop it I never seen Sony do this
before stop it
I mean we can literally Google Sony
layoffs and we probably spend three
hours reading all the people they've
laid off yeah stop it Tom I never seen
Sony dude this happens all of the time
the only reason it's making such a big
no uh a big notice I think there's
multiple reasons one reason is because
they just spent
58 uh 68 billion dollars so it does look
bad on a logistics side uh and another
thing Microsoft's just way bigger than
Sony and when they do layoffs they lay
off way more people because they just
have more staff on on stride I think it
said they like they like four to five
percent of their of their employees the
10 000 people being laid off is only
four percent of their Workforce and I
just mentioned how the last four years
they hired 77 000 people of course
Microsoft is bigger than Sony Chris Hawk
and who is that Harry
why sugarcoat who's sugar coating 10 000
people getting laid off nobody sugarcoat
now that's a lot of people bro
that's a lot of people
Microsoft is a massive company you know
I'm not you know yes we're not sugar so
Harry hold up hold up Harry tell me how
we ain't criticizing tell me how me
saying the company shouldn't be able to
just lay people off without proper cause
or or any type of uh time frame to find
a new job tell me how that's tell me how
that's uh
I I can't even you said no critical
thinking you know tell me how dirt's
saying the reason he likes
he he likes uh
man I just completely spaced
the reason he likes unions is because
they're they can't do stuff like that
how's that critical thinking
see see how these are the type of guys
that that Jess he just joined by
probably two minutes ago
he no he probably knows I'm an Xbox dude
right oh you're just defending Microsoft
without asking you listening to anything
we're saying these other type of guys uh
you know bro Harry
no one brought up PlayStation it was
Chris that brought a PlayStation quiz
heart yes and he was remarking making a
remark off of that we you go go look
that we never talked about PlayStation
Christopher Hart said I don't see
PlayStation people do that and that's
why he said that
so I mean you guys could see here you
could you could sit there and spin this
in any way shape or form you want to
that's fine I don't care
but at the end of the day you know we're
gonna go ahead and get on to the 343
Fiasco it's just crazy that
you know what they want us to come on
here disrespect people
say Xbox is the is the worst company in
the world it just straight up be mad
disrespectful that's all that is their
equivalent to US holding them to the
fire but if you come to them like look
we understand this business you
shouldn't do it this way we feel like
there could have been a different way I
don't like how companies could do this
that's not critical thing I I I don't
know what else to tell you guys I don't
know what else to tell you
yeah
um yeah this hairy guy whatever well
Sony only had 90 people laid off in 2022
okay well what about 2017 2016. shut up
like Alex said the only reason we
brought up Sony's because Chris Hart did
get out of here man we won't feed them
too much I I gave them a little a little
brownie but uh that I'm done getting
brownies all right let's let's go on to
the the three four three the the actual
Halo stuff okay so
343 was part of these layoffs and it
looked like they laid off uh 60 plus
people
um what's interesting
is
there were some articles out saying that
some of those and a lot of those layoffs
was Story related did you see that yeah
yeah yeah yeah like from The Campaign
team I'm like yeah so
are they drifting away from that are
they done trying I I'm kind of curious
how that's going like I I really
yeah what's your opinion yeah man
um 60 people
laid off from the campaign team it does
make you question like whoa are they
still doing the campaign uh I mean
probably so because Halo is not only
known for as multiplayer but is also
known for his campaign and I actually
enjoy Halo infinite's campaign but and I
would like to see more of that story
especially with Halo infinite ending on
a kind of a you know like a tease for uh
like the next part so it made me kind of
say wow you know I um read what Pierre
said the guy that's um
the uh so like the guy that's heading
Halo right now I just had to quote up
I'm sorry he said Pierre he said
something um
sorry you know damn I just had it I'm
I'm sorry bro
I'm sorry I just had it I don't know
what happened to it but
he's oh okay I'm sorry I found it he
said uh we made the difficult decision
to restructure elements of our team
which means some roles are being
eliminated
um so PA is of course the guy that's
running three four three now and I'm
sure it was a tough decision but I'm
curious like you why are they removing
just people from the campaign team
um
I don't know man it really makes you
think and also I know you read that
Joseph stating is um going back to Xbox
Microsoft Global publishing
and I think you can look at that like
one of two ways you can look at that
like
he they brought him into in there to
help finish Halo infinite
um he did his job and now he's going
back to where he was previously or
you can look at it like um
they're just restoration everything and
they just put him back to where he was
before so what does that mean attic this
this is you know I don't know bro
it seems like a demotion to me I'm sorry
like it does
it it's just like how do you go from
running a studio to going back to your
old [ __ ]
well he never ran the studio I mean
he didn't technically run the studio but
he was running the studio
okay it just it is what it is did you
end up um reading that whole article
that I sent you no I didn't read the
whole thing okay so what was the the
overall gist that he just went back
that's pretty much all it said
yeah they say the heat is pretty much
when he's he's he's gone back to uh to
to global global publishing
um and you know That's it man but yeah
like you said the single player team has
the biggest impact
um so
yeah I don't know man it's sad man uh
at this point would you be surprised in
the next year if uh you hear that 343 is
moving on a new project and Halo and
Halos being put on the shelves
Halo infinite is being put on the shelf
or Halo franchise Halo franchise I would
be surprised if that happens yes
now if they say they are doing a sequel
to Halo Infinity I wouldn't be surprised
about that but the Halo franchise I
would definitely be surprised about that
ah it's sad man I honestly felt like
that this studio could do something I
feel like you know at this point maybe
they need to move on to something else
that's not Halo maybe they're too close
to it you know when you don't truly give
a studio
the freedom they need to do stuff that
they want to do I feel like that can
cause issues uh so you know maybe Halo
can bounce back from this you know I
it's looking bad though you know and
what's sad is this Forge dropped and I
felt like it gained so much traction
before
and now the fact that
Joshua staton's leaving
might as well just destroyed all that
all of it like you know be crazy Bonnie
Ross came back
[Laughter]
it's sad man I honestly truly feel like
this studio could do something and uh
you know maybe it's not Halo maybe it
need they need to do something new Maybe
you know when when you when you come out
and you're and you're this studio and
that's all you make maybe that's the
issue and it just feels like these days
you know you don't really know what's
going on until it happens and I I really
do hope that you know they they get
stuff taken care of man like what what
do you think is that is next for Halo
at this point I do think they're going
to continue with the multiplayer stuff
in the seasons I Believe season three is
about to drop pretty soon right
um season three is about to drop pretty
soon I think they're going to continue
with it they're going to keep on adding
new modes I believe it's um what's that
that other team that's working on the
Battle Royale is a creative assembly
maybe
um they're working on the Battle Royale
I think they're going to still focus on
all of the multiplayer stuff but
the single player stuff that's what's
really up in the air at it I just I
still think they're going to do a single
player
because we don't know how many people
was on the campaign
um I'm sure it was more than 60. so we
don't really know but um I'm assuming
they're still going to do the campaign I
can't see them giving a campaign to
somebody else
I can't see that
I think they're going to keep it in
three four three but
um at this point
I'm just going to say
we don't know what's happening we don't
know what's going to happen the game
still plays well like I said I played it
right before the podcast it still plays
well it runs well you can get you can
still get into a game pretty fast season
three is coming soon but we'll see what
happens in the future bro I just don't
know I'm I'm sorry certain Infinity
Jacob J my bad
yep so oh so that wasn't a real Chris
heart
oh sorry about that well both Chris
hearts are POS
s yeah I mean but it wouldn't surprise
me Christopher came in here with some
stuff like that game in Forte said the
campaign would be a part of a different
game not Halo infinite hey uh Forte we
need to talk
yeah we need to talk Forte there's a lot
of stuff I can't say there's a lot of
stuff I can't say uh but you know
I think that
I'm gonna just be real I think I think
343 needs to work on something new
yeah
yeah like sometimes you know people want
to do something new you know yeah I
think
if anything if you if you want them to
keep them on the Halo franchise
split that studio in half let half of
them work on this and half of them work
on that
uh you know that's probably better for
everybody
it is it is what it is though at this
point
there's nothing we can really do with
that it just it needs to be one of those
things where something needs to change
because whatever's working is not
working you got too many people leaving
back and forth whatever is working is
not working something needs to change
you know it's funny is I'm friends with
JW and I know a lot of people don't like
Jada but but it's cool I get it he's
made a lot of enemies uh you know his
his Persona on Twitter it's a little too
much sometimes and when he calls me and
I see his name I'm like ah
ah like I know what he's gonna he and
every time something really bad happens
on Xbox
I hear him laugh
yeah it's it's
one before too yeah oh he's a good dude
I get it like he's too much
but he doesn't there's I was in several
DMS with him and he did he never stops I
said bro I can't deal with this I feel
you I've told her multiple times man you
need to lay off that Persona a little
bit find out super truck from El Nina
best scenario for Halo is Microsoft buy
certain affinity and give the IP to them
Max overread is the only hope hover
hover man I don't I don't know who that
is
um
okay okay let me ask you a question
let's let's get a little bit fun with
this uh I say we got about another 10
minutes before I'm wrapping this up okay
Halo 343 keeps the multiplayer
they Outsource the single player to
another Studio that they own who would
you want to do
that they own hmm
most people say Ed software because
they're really good at um
you know doing first person shooters but
I would say check this out arcane
I would say RK Arcane is a crazy thought
a crazy thing okay that game that would
be the most original Halo game ever
um
yeah that's what I would say I'm sure
you machine games machine gun machine
games oh yeah you know what I forgot
about that oh that's a good one you know
what yeah I was gonna see I would go
machine I forgot about them because I
love the Wolfenstein games
yeah that's a double but when it comes
to what hold on obviously want to say
Arcane because the Sci-Fi aspect see the
reason I say machine games is
I I think of something like the
beginning of
uh Wolfenstein the last one where he's
rolling through the hallway in the chair
and he's putting his foot on there but
like imagine
that type of set pieces but with Halo
yeah that would be fire but yeah but but
do you honestly feel like Halo might
need to go a little bit of like the
adult gory side with the single player
though I would be fine with that yeah
like imagine fighting like you're
fighting a an elite an elite pulls up on
you and master chief like he he's coming
up with the sword and master chief like
takes his elbow and just sticks himself
with it like the the and you just see
the blood coming off the sword like how
I think that would be good man I think
the single player might need to go
because here's the thing I didn't mind
what they made with Halo infinite I
thought that open world was okay I
thought it was a lot of forms it was
dead inside I feel like the actual
things was what I wanted like you know
how like there was like sections of the
map I kind of felt like they should have
went towards the Far Cry 5 Direction
where certain sections of the map was on
was ran by a certain Elite yeah or
Covenant or banished and you had to do
stuff in that area it to get him to come
out yeah let's say that there was like a
command or a banshees and as long as he
was alive there was like crazy banshees
going through the map you know what I'm
saying and but when you killed him he
was he was able to do more air stuff
there you uh you know you unlocked your
own aerial compact I thought would have
been cool stuff like that but
I personally feel like Halo needs to go
back to linear
were set pieces everything don't need to
be open where I agree with you yeah
imagine Halo 4. Halo 4 I felt like the
story could have been better but the the
infrastructure and what the story is
built on was good
it's just I felt like they could have
fluffed it out better than they did like
we didn't need to fight homeboy five six
times yeah yeah there was a lot of
information that they gave us that I
felt like points on my five it's not my
five yeah shout out to the 306 people in
the chat man hit that like button you
guys let's get that up like button let
me hit it I even hit it uh hit the like
button what's wrong with me man
but that that's how I feel um people say
Doom I don't I don't I don't think it
should should make it I'm gonna be real
with you I think we're doing yeah
I love doing that that's a fast this
game is fast as hell you know I know
they have the story down for Halo but
nah I I stand by my Arcane though and I
would say arcane
Austin well I'll wait to play redfall
first but I can't Leon the ones that
made Dead uh um I want arcane
to make dishonored again we got a two
dollar super shot from Sir X-Men uh
remedies should do the next Halo story
time manipulation when Master Chief
watch I don't want that though all right
I'm gonna be right with you I don't want
the time
from Carl Andrews Jr I hope that's not
your name man change it if it is what
could epic games do with Halo epic games
they would shade sell the hell out of
that game oh what's up Gene Park give
Halo to Todd Pierre chaos are you saying
Todd Howard are you saying God Howard
yo that would be crazy imagine if
Bethesda made a Halo game that would be
crazy imagine imagine
if you started
Halo okay yeah what I was gonna say is I
would like Arcane to make a
a Dishonored and dead Loop a death Loop
mix like a a combined uh it would be
cool if imagine a Halo infinite
not Halo infinite a Halo game that's
like an open world game you start as
just a regular Marine you're working
your way up you could go either
direction you could join the Covenant if
you want to like imagine like an open
world game like that I think that would
be dope man I think that would be dope
like a BioWare type game like a mass
effect type game in the Halo Universe
interesting stuff man
or imagine at the beginning you could
choose to be like an elite or something
and you you're born in that world you
have to like fight your way to be in the
Covenant or you can be you could join
the the humans like it'd be cool man it
would be cool
yeah yeah I'd be different that'd be
definitely different
all right but you know I appreciate it
for coming through man uh oh that that's
another thing I would like for them to
do the Arbiter has a huge expanse of
life and I think
the Coalition should make an Arbiter
game
it's a third person action adventure
gory ass game imagine like you're the
Arbiter and you're reaching over
grabbing them and just cutting off like
their chest their abdomen you know what
I'm saying like because that's who the
Arbiter is he's a very aggressive
individual five dollars from uh el Nina
once Microsoft owns Blizzard have them
make a Halo MMO
I don't want a bunch of focus on Halo
though I'm going to be real like
I think Halo's a great franchise and
maybe I would prefer that 343 work on
something new but if they want to keep
it around I just don't want a bunch of
new projects with Halo because I want
them to experiment and give
opportunities to other to these
developers to make something new uh
because I feel like that's one of the
issues that we have in the industry
right now is people are getting too
comfortable with franchises and instead
of trying to make a new IP which is
risky and I will I will never say that
they should because I know it's a risky
business and the wrong IP can ruin your
whole company but what I will say
is I feel like people are getting too
comfortable with making franchises that
they're not experiencing is enough and
we're not getting better games
yeah I think that's the time that we're
living in adding up people are you know
these companies they're hesitant
to invest money in a new IP that's why
we're getting so many remakes and so
many sequels
because they like Calista protocol is a
perfect example of a beautiful game a
game I actually like but it kind of
flopped and that game had a pretty
massive budget you know we do dirt and I
don't know how you feel about this Gene
let's just let's just shake it up let's
let's give I think I've said this to the
four let's give three four three gears
and let's give uh uh Coalition Halo and
just yeah like make a first person third
person you make a third person a first
person and see how that goes it'd be
interesting I wonder who would make the
better game I think it'd be coalition I
think Coalition gas don't come here with
that mess some of guys was right no I
did you ever did you ever uh
calm your people with fake people
uh not really
you know just like a cease-fire kind of
thing when it kind of calm down guys
that made a video and then flared right
back up so you know they're still mad at
gas gas like whatever so it's kind of
like you know
yeah that's what it is
so and I do feel like there does come to
a point where the line between joking
and being disrespectful is is crossed
um the sad part is we're into we're
different individuals different people
that line is different for everyone and
some people they they don't know if what
the difference is it's sad because I do
feel like this is about gaming you guys
let's keep it gaming and sometimes you
know uh people want to smoke they get to
smoke so we gotta find out from cloaked
or Onyx one of the major issues is that
Halo infinite didn't explore the lore of
Zeta Halo so much history happened to
that Halo and it's only in the books I
agree yeah there's a lot of stuff they
can do uh but you know we're gonna go
ahead what no I'm saying yeah I agree
with him
yeah so we're gonna go ahead and uh get
this out of here man I try to keep these
like an hour and a half maximum uh you
know I appreciate it for coming through
though but but dirt working the audience
find you put your stuff in the chat man
yeah I'm spam it spam it uh check out my
YouTube channel uh dirt griggly I have a
podcast on Monday evenings called um WBZ
Xbox podcast let me get my
WBZ Xbox podcast I do you know content
check it out I have a lot of fun and I
always say this if you are a PlayStation
Fanboy you probably won't like my
channel
but if you're Xbox fan that loves little
trash talking he loves to have fun I try
to keep it entertaining
check it out Chris heart hey you can't
tell me unblock you
everybody my mind's block you bro cause
you come in there with the foolishness
you know I will admit Chris
if this is the real Chris you do come in
like it would be different if you came
in just to chat it up and then you and
then you started doing the uh the
foolishness but you come in you come in
like you like a lot of people come in
there they want to just joke around they
knock on the door and then when we
opened then they started you kicked the
door open with the console war stuff
yeah bro it's like last week on my boy
Sean 786 Channel
um he came in we were talking we were
really talking about Xbox at that time
we were talking about Xbox and the uh a
developers Direction and the first thing
he said when he came in PlayStation
video is going to kill all y'all at like
what he was like bro we are over here
talking about we really talk about Xbox
no Contour stuff at that time we were
just talking about what they expect
we're talking about red fall Ford son
he's like PlayStation VR is going to
destroy anything Xbox drop this year and
blah blah come on man
we got a five dollar Superstar from El
Nina I appreciate you super chatting a
lot el Nina you you've been you've been
you've been I hope I'm pronouncing your
name right that'd be horrible but we're
gonna move past that the whole point
behind 343 was to make Halo I'm sorry
but I have no interest in anything else
from them I feel you but if they made
good games I think you would you would
think differently do you see what I'm
saying uh uh
dirt I feel like people have people have
every right to have that mentality but I
feel like if if 343 have been secretly
working on a game they dropped it this
year in the holiday and it was a good
game people would be like I like this
let's let's new experiment man new
experiment five dollars from uh thanrios
is that how he spoke yeah that's a
little light don't understand the 343
height 33 has a parent company which is
Microsoft I'm pretty sure all three four
three balloons were the fault of
Microsoft uh I don't think I it's like I
said earlier I think it's a give and
take it's a little bit Xbox fault a
little bit PlayStation uh PlayStation's
fault a little bit um Microsoft's fault
a little bit of 343's fault like
for infinite right yeah I do feel like
maybe 343 was
was highly encouraged to make a
a games as a service Halo and maybe they
just weren't equipped to do it you know
what I'm saying
um because if you really look on that
look I play I play fortnite you look
through the stuff you can get stuff you
can buy the stuff you can earn a lot of
it's fun oh this is cool this is cool
you look through that three four three
Halo infinite merchandise that you could
get through the season pass or by
there's not you you could look different
but it's not drastically you know what
I'm saying like your mask is a circle
instead of a triangle you know what I'm
saying like
yeah I I think they could do better in
the Cosmetic Department I do I think the
uh flame said I blame the series s it's
serious asphalt
the layoffs is the series asphalt right
I feel you guys I feel you all right but
we're gonna go ahead and wrap this up
man uh put put your stuff in the chat
again man spam it in there uh I will we
will be doing uh the iron Lords podcast
this 1pm now we do have a guest uh
normally we don't do guests back to back
anymore but uh we do have a guest
and
I'm curious if I tell you on a scale
from one to ten how mad [ __ ] would be
I don't know say nothing then yeah maybe
it's best I don't say they they can wait
till Saturday for the marketing for the
video
because I could just see I could see Cog
now why did you tell them he wouldn't
get like upset with me he would just be
like may you know I like to show that
for the for for Twitter right so yeah
yeah I could feel that I could feel that
look at look at look at Donna talking
just tell us we're not gonna tell it's
live I can't hide well you act like am I
going to tell them it's attic with a c
that's who said it not me I could keep a
secret yeah can all 240 people in the
chat right now keep you secret I I think
the first thing you guys will do is go
on Twitter and Tack hog and sit and said
ADD extension that's the first thing you
guys would do and I ain't giving you
guys the satisfaction but I appreciate
you ever coming through this is Lord
addict and dirt griggity definitely
check out his his uh his podcast man he
does it Mondays my bot podcast my bot
Channel come on Box come on yeah yeah
definitely go check that out what's up
slo-mo look everyone decided to show up
like at the very end man at the very end
but I appreciate it for coming through
uh if you guys there is time stamps uh I
did get all the time stamps I'm stabbed
the right attic I didn't do the intros I
didn't do the outro one so you know the
times that police gonna have to get over
that one uh the outro zero zero zero I
don't care because to me
why are you trying to do a timestamp to
the outros
that makes no sense does that make sense
to you
I do a timestamp I don't believe now
that you say that it doesn't make sense
people believe on the outros yeah that
lets people know when the conversation
the last conversation is going to be
over I I mean the the end of the show's
over in the yeah yeah it makes sense
outro meaning that's the beginning of
people saying yo I'm out of here yo
check out my channel so I guess I don't
know yeah we're we're gonna ring up the
guests on here you know I gotta talk to
gotta talk to dirt find out what kind of
people he likes uh having on but I
appreciate it for coming through this is
a gaming addict Lord addict and dirt and
uh we'll talk to you later all right be
sure to put your Twitter in the